[Musique]
c'est pas passé
l'agent
[Musique]
on retourne en 1984 ce matin ça fait des
décennies qu'il chante l'amour et le
country 50 ans de carrière 33 album une
tournée qui est toujours en cours une
nouvelle exposition dont il nous parle
ce matin et patrick normand bonjour
merci d'être avec nous ce matin
bonjour comme très content d'être là est
ce que ça vous rend nostalgique un peu
de vous revoir comme ça il ya presque 40
ans à la télévision en 1984
je les vois souvent ces images là à
travers mon travail et tout ça mais
c'est
ce qui me ce qui me frappe dans tout ça
c'est que le temps passé tellement vite
que j'ai un peu de difficulté à
concevoir que j'ai pu faire toutes ces
choses là à l'espace d'une vie en
l'espace d'une cinquantaine d'années
c'est ici et j'ai fait des grandes
rencontres
ggg frayé avec dédé des monstres de deux
des artistes monstre qui qui qui avait
une carrière mondiale comme ça et d'être
avec eux qui mettent un peu d'importance
ça m'a toujours
encouragé à poursuivre dans ce que je
faisais
qui sait si c'est pour moi des scellés
plus les plus beaux souvenirs qu'on peut
se
montrer au musée ici que j'ai fait le
tour justement hier j'ai voulu faire
genre de
vol d'oiseau et puis j'ai été touché
tellement profondément vraiment j'étais
touché parce que ce que j'ai vu parce
que peut-être parce que jésus est qu 6
me et elle m'en souvenais qui on va
faire surface surtout quand on faisait
la recherche je sais pas plus ça fait
plus d'un an et demi qu'on travaille
là-dessus oui il fouille dans le fond
des boîtes vides et mes tiroirs on
retrouve des photos puis concevoir des
photos qu'on a pas vu depuis monde oui
c'est ça pour expliquer aux gens patrick
normand voulu parler d'une exposition de
photos qui commence pour célébrer vos
cinquante ans de carrière donc un musée
qui se trouve à drummondville le musée
de la photographie des jardins de chaque
photo que vous avez sélectionné avec
soin puis qui vous a rappelé
certainement beaucoup beaucoup de
souvenirs
et ses photos ont été
bonifiés avec toutes les nouvelles
technologies qu'on a aujourd'hui on
pourra prendre des photos où ils s'en
vont photo flambant neuf et de les
revoir comme savaient que l'impression
profondeur
oh lalala lalala relations avec les
juifs
c'est un magnifique tu ces photos alors
oui je partage
la plupart ont pas été vu par personne
c'est de garder ça chez moi comme
s'ouvrir dans mes archives - personnel
alors quand on recense opinion des
maisons où il a encadré et tout
je vois que j'ai un bon parcours
que ça va donner un bon coup d'émotion
aussi de devoir tout à fait défini d'un
coup sur coup aux larmes oui oui comme
ans est née cette idée de projet
d'aller exposer dans un musée votre
carrière patrick normand ben c'est sûr
que ça vient pas de moi
c'est le musée qui nous aura plus petits
nous on a coché
est
inconnue comment s'amuser je ne
considère pas dans cette dans ce créneau
de là mais après quand on constate la
carrière qu'on qu'on a eu plus d'impact
et cette histoire d'amour qui dure
depuis
sept décennies avec le public avec
l'autre histoire c'est quand même
a souligné je pense j'ai vu c'est avec
une grande grande humilité que gm quand
j'ai terminé maintenant le temps du
musée j'étais aux larmes et j'acceptais
vraiment je suis je me revois encore
gage d'une grande humilité à accepter
tout ça et
c'est un grand bonheur
c'est un façon de
souligner mon travail que j'ai pu faire
la traite toutes ces années
publicité
sa retraite également quand on parle de
votre carrière mais l'exposition photos
nous plonge aussi dans un demi-siècle de
l'histoire de la chanson country aussi
parce que vous faites intégrante fait
partie intégrante en fait du country de
son histoire la culture
j'ai géré at gérante rires je me
considère dans le temps je me considère
pas comme un artiste contenu je me
considère comme un chanteur guitariste
qui s'amusent qui fait de la bonne
musique autant que possible et je me
considérais poche faire juste du conduit
j'ai toujours été dans des bains douches
faisais des conneries on faisait des
réinterprétations de deux chansons des
beatles autant que des du de chicago que
tu me demandes blues
j'ai fait tous les aspects musicaux qui
que jamais moi parce qu'il a mis dès que
j'aime la musique quelques ce soit quant
lui que ce soit au jazz quant à elle
balaie pas m'amuser à l'or
mais on je suis entré par la porte du
contenu parce que j'ai été un peu un
petit peu tancé par l'élite au début de
ma carrière on connaît plus ou moins au
sérieux et
mais je persiste et puis je je me disais
il ya personne qui peut m'enlever le
pendant là que j'ai à jouer à faire de
la musique à jouer de la guitare ah non
je continue quand même ça avoir le désir
de percer c'était pour maman de
motivation situe pas d'être connu le
chemin faire ce métier donc j'adore
tellement bien fait de poursuivre et et
de persévérer et patrick normand vous
avez annoncé votre retraite après une
tournée d'adieu qui est en cours ton ex
hercules si on y allait le tour n'est
qu'il n'est pas fini je pense qu'il
reste quelques spectacles encore au elle
débute à peine et b c'est le temps 2022
parce que tout était mis tout ça parce
qu'on était en suisse étaient sensibles
partir en 2020 j'ai enregistré un album
sans 2019 que je soulignais 50 ans de
carrière je suis à la nage ville j'ai
dit je me paie pour 50 ans cariat je
veux pas eu à faire un album avec les
meilleurs musiciens que sur lesquels je
peux mais je peux mettre la main
des noms que vous ne connaissez
peut-être pas mais aussitôt que vous
mentionnez c'est non
autour de vous jeunes musiciens tous les
soirs où il joue sur ton attendu c'était
des réactions comme ça que j'avais à
chaque fois que je l'annonçais les amis
ça fait que quand je voulais vous de sa
diva quelque chose
lui pendant deux 2 ans sur la glace et
puis les bâtonnets commence à peine et
je me dis moi si je me fie à mes
anciennes tournées ça dure toujours 3 4
des x 5 1 avant une tournée ah ouais
avec les supplémentaires et tout ça
c'est assez s'étend sur plusieurs années
dans le sud ils viendront 75
aux jouets proche de 80 est-ce que je
vais être en train de me pencher sur une
nouvelle tournée et peut-être inscrits
encore capable de me pencher
probablement premièrement
80 personnes en tout cas bah oui je le
suivais un moment présent
mais oui les deux maillots sport
et on va en profiter vous voir dans vos
spectacles dans les prochaines années
cette tournée commence à peine
finalement et puis allez voir cette
exposition c'est au musée de la
photographie des jardins à drummondville
jusqu'au 19 décembre prochain patrick
normand merci infiniment d'avoir été là
merci beaucoup
merci à vous ben
oui pas besoin de vous aussi au vent